Barry come on up from hex Iran from
gitlab Greg from GitHub
GitHub GitHub uh Craig from Jasper and
of course Sean from dataworks
[Music]
sorry
Okay so So today we're gonna spend a
little bit of time going deep into the
world of generative AI large language
models Foundation models and this is an
incredible panel that we pull together
that's been really focused on applied
use cases and you know the big tldr that
you'll see out of this is the Incredible
use cases that are occurring in the
generative world are quite varied and
quite profound so uh let's just start
off with the easy questions uh what's
happening in generative AI today and why
is this happening in such a accelerated
fashion than we've ever seen in sort of
years of work in artificial intelligence
and machine learning maybe Sean you want
to start okay yeah I'll take a shot I
think most of the answer is chat GPT
um that got people to notice generative
AI it's actually been coming along fast
but it's been coming for a couple years
now but this got everyone to perk up
there and listen and when you do take a
look all of a sudden even as a
practitioner you realize there's a lot
more going on than chat GPT and it is
fascinating to me how
accessible these large language models
are you put text in you get text out or
images out it's a very intuitive user
surface and that's why I think
um it's not mixed it's not just
interesting for your average user like
my mom but for for practitioners who
have real use cases they really do some
interesting stuff and that's why I think
everyone's rushing now to figure out
what can this do how does this work and
how do I get in on it
and as you guys have like all started to
apply generative use cases and
particularly you know building either
specific domain oriented large language
models I mean certainly the announcement
with Dolly this past week uh Greg some
of the work that you're doing right now
at Jasper starting with openai but then
extending that to other large language
models just tell us a little bit more
maybe Greg as a starting point like what
surprised you guys through this journey
of um what you thought you were getting
and what you got out of building with a
generative first experience yeah I think
uh to your point about chat gbt I think
like that woke the world up to the power
of what these models could do and it
woke up not just the the AI early
adopters and nerds and those people that
were like really into it but it was It
was kind of the Moms and Pops it was the
big businesses that now couldn't afford
to ignore this the small businesses
everyone was really turned on to it and
as we started we we had been working on
some things earlier on and I think a lot
of what we found is that uh we could get
an edge and create a better experience
for users by trying to figure out how to
leverage these models as best we could
and really trying to understand them and
I think what we found that was a little
surprising or maybe not I guess but
looking back now is just like how much
of a black box they really kind of are
and trying to understand almost if each
model is like a different almost Persona
of AI is maybe as like freaky as that
gets you know talking about AI that way
but um thinking of it like they each
have their own strengths and weaknesses
and they're not always obvious and so
trying to explore like Which models are
good for which use cases and and which
ways and then understanding maybe how to
experiment around those things with the
the not so obvious use cases what we
found is that like open AI their models
definitely have a certain sort of like
Persona or a certain like set of
strengths and weaknesses that are kind
of common to a lot of them whereas other
providers some models that we've created
in-house at Jasper they all kind of have
like different I don't know veins or
threads of like what they're really good
at and what they're maybe weak at and
what we found is that even though they
become super powerful that you could
take any of them off the shelf and do a
lot with them it's still never like a
one size fits-all at least in like the
best you could get out of them there's
still like a combination of things that
you could do leveraging either different
models or like a large language model
something else to really produce the
best you know whether it's text output
or image output or whatever it is
um so it's been it's been a lot of
experimenting and finding that trying to
really get uh inside the model so to
speak isn't really where we've had
success it's kind of been just honestly
experimenting and trialing things and
combining things and seeing what we can
understand about them from that
perspective so let's pull out a thread a
little bit uh you indicated that models
have personalities right and so uh
there's a world view that there's
potentially a single model emerging we
won't name who's building that
um that there is a possibility for AGI
coming out of this single model emerging
Barry you had some thoughts before we
got on stage in terms of like is that
the way Enterprises are going to consume
things over time or is there a different
world view that's also emerging
simultaneously well I uh I don't have a
strong world view on like how imminent
AGI is I think there's so much smarter
people or I just quoted in Reuters this
morning about that I said no AGI is not
along its way so I I took a position on
it for a reason I think there's an
interesting thing
um when we go and talk to customers
especially larger customers both within
the context of hex but also just more
broadly on like how they're thinking
about using and applying uh generative
AI I think there's this interesting
opportunity and challenge
that you're going to see people using
lots and lots of models I mean today we
think we think generative AI there's
like effectively one API that you can go
and use open AI but I think a year from
now there's going to be at least a dozen
the ones we know about ones we don't
know about
he loved the big cloud players lots of
startups and I think what you're going
to see is uh companies and and I know
Jasper they're doing this they're
adopting you know behind the product
like a bunch of different models that
can be used I think you're going to see
big corporations do this and across all
the different surface areas and what
they're where they're using generative
AI both internally and for their
products and so I think you're going to
see a super heterogeneous
um landscape of of different models and
different things that people are using
either just different providers because
this department had a better
relationship with this other company or
models that are purpose-built or fit for
purpose for different types of things or
a thing you find find tune for a single
um a single use case I think that's
going to create a lot of uh chaos I
think it's going to create a lot of
confusion Within These big companies I
mean anyone here has ever worked at a
big company or if you're selling to a
big company you know that they if you go
and ask them like oh what do you use for
data warehousing if you go to ask like a
big Bank what do you use for data
storage and data warehouse and there's
like everything we have one of
everything you're going to see the same
thing with these models and I think
there's an interesting Challenge and
opportunity around managing that and
observing those and understanding um how
those things are performing and uh
almost also the risk associated with
that
you don't at
um your time particularly in focused on
co-pilot all right and and the work that
the team at GitHub has done I mean for
anyone who's sort of had an experience
around co-pilot it's probably the most
profound change in programming that
we've seen in
probably a decade or more
so
how is that sort of human machine
interface sort of changed using
generative Ai and particularly like how
does that persona for the developer in
this case you know find a different way
of working and was that what you were
going about doing when you guys went
down the co-pilot route
um
and where do you see this go from this
moment on well it's not a that's not a
big question at all
um
wow well I
I gotta I gotta admit I was a skeptic in
the beginning like when we first started
out uh with coped at like you know three
two and a half years ago
um there wasn't chat it wasn't the age
of AI it was sort of the first mass
Market
application of generative Ai and the
truth is is that it's uh I was I was
very glad to be wrong like you know it
turned out to be actually incredibly
useful to the point where I never want
to code without it again it's incredibly
helpful but I I think we're just
starting to scratch the surface like
there's more modalities ghost text is is
not the be-all and end-all of of
generative AI like yeah it's got a lot
of great qualities but that's not the
only way that things uh can be
definitely more applications like we're
looking at copilot outside of the editor
like how can we help developers with all
of these other tasks and bring uh
generative AI to help with like not just
writing tests or writing code but also
helping me collaborate and summarize and
bring other people into the discussion
with me
um docs that's like a huge part of like
what we do as developers is you know
looking at the documentation trying to
figure out how do I do the thing that I
want to do how can we basically speed
people along that curve you know if you
think of the computer as an instrument
like how do we get people to play their
first song how do we get more people to
play this instrument
um I think we have a generational
opportunity right now to bring more
people into the field that maybe don't
have the advantages I had coming up uh
and uh where previously we've said like
oh you know it would be really nice if
we could get more diversity into
computer science now we actually have
the tools to make that happen so I look
at that when I think about the future of
uh generative stuff at the end of the
day I want to give bionic like
capabilities to developers I want them
to like step into this like exoskeleton
that's like powered and like whatever
they want to do they can like lift
buildings and jump really high and I
don't know whatever so
um by any means and in a lot of
different situations it's no longer
going to be like oh here's one feature
in one situation it's going to be a
million things and million situations
and use as Jasper said uh sorry not
Jasper Dragon
[Laughter]
um uh a lot of different models in order
to accomplish that it's not going to be
like one model fits all well great you
kind of alluded to something which is
like the the models have their own
personas right and in essence most
software companies have gone to a level
of scale and succeeded they found the
Persona that they pursue and like really
tailor their products and and
capabilities to that Persona is there a
world and maybe Jasper's probably one of
the first highlights where there's one
model per human Persona one machine llm
Persona per human Persona just talk
about that a little bit more in Jasper's
experience in transforming how content
writers work today yeah yeah and so
maybe for a little bit of background for
those who don't know about Jasper you
know our main Target customer I'd say is
is business people people working
professionally to create content
um the most obvious use case being
people on marketing teams but really can
extend to anyone creating content it
could be you know Engineers creating
documentation things like that too but
um yeah what we've found is is early on
we started to discover that customers
users is really have this desire to have
a large language model or what they
thought of as like a large language
model but generally they wanted AI that
was more accustomed to what they were
doing and more personalized for them
that could speak like them or know them
know about them have facts about them
all those different types of things
instead of feeling kind of generic
because like after a while using
especially some of the earlier models
even from openai you start to kind of
see these patterns where okay it's it's
great but it does start to kind of feel
generic and it's harder to like
differentiate between like who's using
the model to create the content and
really it almost becomes more the model
itself and so some of the first things
that we looked into was what would it
look like to create models for every
customer and you know obviously like at
first glance you realize like that's not
the most economical way to handle that
if you're looking at creating a you know
175 billion parameter model for every
customer we've got you know however many
customers that's not going to scale very
well at all
um and but even aside from that we
started to kind of poke at things around
that and found that from our experience
that and then this kind of comes back to
us saying before about like the models
are kind of these like black boxes and
when you try to like open them up and
and do like whether it's like a lot of
like fine-tuning to an existing model or
something like that we found there's
actually different ways to get the
desired uh result without doing those
things where I guess long story short
instead of creating like a whole new
model for every person or for every use
case or for every uh you know whatever
it is personality that you want there's
things that you can do around that model
to create that desired effect
um you know there's been a lot of things
coming out recently in the Press about
you know companies finding a lot of
success including Jasper with like
vector databases and Vector search with
large language models or things you can
do with adapter models or things you can
do uh even just with you know more
traditional AI Technologies in concert
with large language models to create a
more personalized experience so it might
not be that you have your own large
language model that's for you but you
have sort of this like orchestration of
Technologies working in concert that
does uh fit you and fit your use case
and fit uh you know may understand more
about you
um that's a lot of what we've in fact
I'll say the biggest thing that we're
focused on right now that we're
releasing features around is the idea of
uh you know there's maybe generic
off-the-shelf large language models
they're very powerful but then how do we
personalize them how do we make them uh
more suited for what we're specifically
doing either as companies or even as
individuals
one of the things that I had a chance to
talk about more recently is the fact
that every
software category is going to need this
idea of its own specific category
dominant large language model but it's
not just about that large language model
like it's the fact that you still have
to build great ux you still have to
build a great workflow and certainly
Jasper's experience you know uh sort of
really shows what's possible for those
of you who don't know Jasper is either
the second or the fastest growing
software company ever
um as of this past year so
uh Sean
so
databricks doesn't have to do any of
this stuff like your billion dollar
business now it's been an incredible
journey to watch what you and Ali and
the rest of the team has accomplished in
the last
um you know going on a decade now right
yeah but just about um congrats on this
journey
um
why did you guys go down this path of
like announcing and even working on
something like Dolly um what was the
creative impetus uh where do you see
this impact of uh you know where
everyone went down this path of like
building these you know several hundred
million dollar expenditure of compute
large language models you guys come back
and spend thirty dollars on uh a model
called Dolly which has um potentially
even outperformed some of the models
that have been in market today yeah
that's worth explaining and I should say
I I work clue with that team I won't
take credit for for what that team did
Mike and mate and all them of course
um but yeah let me work backwards to how
we got there because databricks isn't
really a researchy type of company by
Nature
um and I think what was received and the
announcement wasn't quite the point uh
yeah there was a model that got created
but it was really more about the idea
and the process maybe I don't need a
massive model to be good at a specific
thing and I think that's that's not even
necessarily news that's an idea that was
had I think weeks before you heard about
Dolly so it makes more sense if you see
I think what we see I see at databricks
from customers hearing about chat GPT
yes now everyone is infused with a mix
of fomo and fear I need this this looks
like it's going to change everything
what does it do and how do I get on top
of it before it gets on top of me and
then fear as you look at the dominant
player in the space open AI which is
great actually it's good value for money
it's a great model and certainly from if
your Enterprise hat on maybe your data
hat on you say well this is a little
scary I'm going to send my data to this
company and Trust they're going to give
me answers back and keep it secure I
need to do this in-house and then you
realize you can't do it in-house just
off the shelf it took every these
researchers years and millions and
millions of dollars so that doesn't seem
realistic and then maybe you also
separately observe that the real
bottleneck in all this is data it's not
the compute it's not the research it's
not the tools that's fairly commodity
but data and the thing you need to do
with your with these llms is probably
not you don't need an AGI you probably
don't need a chatbot you're trying to
fill out RFP responses from your
previous RFP responses and you have that
data sets that openai doesn't so all
this kind of leads you to this knee like
I want something that can feasibly
manage in my own model help me do that
on my data and that's why this idea that
came out of Stanford really was so
appealing to jump on and push sure take
a take a big base model take your data
tune it in a pretty easy way to get
something let's say the single billions
of parameter size which is pretty
manageable and that is going to be a
minor subplot in this whole story for I
think this year well we're going to
spend a little bit of time on our lhf
and private data I'm going to come back
to that but before I do that
um you know Barry you made some pretty
interesting choices going down the path
of hex magic right and it's it's a
wildly beautiful experience to see what
uh a generative SQL experience could
look like
um tell us like what were the trade-offs
like you know clearly you built on top
of open AI
um it's been a you know seems like a
pretty positive experience tell everyone
how the journey has gone yeah
um
so just for folks who don't know so we
released uh earlier this year a feature
called Magic and hex which is basically
you know the shorthand pitch is like
copilot for data
uh to to just piggyback off Edon as
usual
um uh and it allows users to generate
edit debug and document uh analytics
code so if you're writing SQL or python
or R in HEX you can invoke these magic
assistants
that will come and help you do that and
I think we had actually first prototyped
this a year ago we had a hack week it
was like exactly a year ago it was like
April 11th I was just looking at it uh
the other day where we had done a first
version of this using the gpt3 API which
was available all the time and the API
wasn't quite ready it was kind of shaky
and also like it wasn't clear to us how
exactly this was going to get used
because I think our fear or the thing we
had initially thought was like oh this
can just like generate the thing for you
in one in like one shot
and I think as we iterated on it and we
sort of came back to it over the summer
and fall of last year the Insight that
really we we zoned in on and the thing
we decided to really adopt is our core
focus with the magic features was this
is about augmenting and accelerating the
current users we have we have thousands
of people who use hex every day to ask
and answer questions of data to build
visualizations like mission one for us
on everything we do is making these
people's lives better and
um
I I really think that like using that as
our sort of central Focus it's not about
like hey all of data work and all of
data professionals are going to be
replaced by some like black box or like
some one text box where a business
stakeholder comes in and like types some
question and gets back up perfectly
formatted answer with properly built
charts and explanations and all of that
like I don't think that's gonna happen
anytime soon and so for us it was really
about how do we incorporate these
generative features in the existing
workflow in a way that feels really um
magic and so you know we we had to do
even as we were iterating on it there
was some really new UI things we kind of
had to break into in Canada I think one
of the most exciting things about
generative AI as a product Builder is it
is like for the first time in a long
time like a new UI surface area like
we're we're going on a while like since
like 2008 really with the invent you
know the the App Store coming out of
like kind of the same UI stuff you know
and it's like this kind of new exciting
Frontier and Surf and and front on ux
and so for us it was it was fun and it's
been fun and we've got more stuff coming
down the pike in terms of like what does
it look like to have a human partner
with software in this sort of assistant
way like one's mind jumps forward or
jumps back I suppose to like clippy you
know is it like this little assistant
that hangs out alongside
um and so that that was really fun and I
think um uh you know that we were
alluding earlier to like it's about the
ux I think that the apis the the AI
itself is a commodity more or less and
and I don't mean to align the Nuance of
like okay are you using like an
off-the-shelf one or using something
like Dolly just you know deploy your own
but like access to the base loms is a
commodity everyone here can go spin up
an open AI account right now it's how do
you package that in the UI that in ux
that's really really thoughtful about
like the the interaction it's going to
have with the human the feedback loops
and what that how that changes the way
people are working and that's been the
really fun and really exciting thing for
us like within the domain of of data you
know one thing that andrewing called
last year
um was that everything that we've known
in the AI World particularly around
machine learning is really pushing
itself from a model Centric to a data
Centric world right and it's to point
Berry like the models are becoming so
ubiquitous right whether you get it off
the shelf whether you build it whether
you've you know curated from a number of
like sources where you're kind of
building your own Ensemble across these
models it's still a data Centric world
so when we think about that data Centric
world I mean there's an incredible
number of uh awesome data Engineers here
how do we have to think about this from
a data engineering standpoint
um you know do llms need their own
special storage do we have to think
about ETL or elt differently now that we
have this sort of massive rise of llms
in the market is Vector database is the
thing
I don't know if anyone doesn't matter I
may not I'll definitely draft on on what
Barry said that like the end goal needs
to be uh happiness satisfaction and how
do you deliver that by any means
um I think
how those those underlying data
Primitives change
depends a lot on where we're going next
there's a lot of talk about like you
know how are we going to make LMS
stronger better how are we going to
train them are we going to fine tune
them and that costs a lot of money and
it's kind of like oh I have all this
horsepower I need more horsepower when
in reality I don't think that we've
really fully tapped the power of the
models that we have today and so you
asked about Vector databases I see a lot
of
um mileage still to get out of
techniques like retrieval where instead
of fine tuning which costs money and
needs gpus that maybe I don't have and
everybody else wants
but if I can do embeddings and then use
that to better craft prompts then I can
elicit better responses from the models
the models I have today not the models
that we'll train to model tomorrow and
then I also don't need to train my own
models I can use the off the shelf ones
but get more specific to my purpose
responses out of them that the vast
majority of the effort we are putting in
that our team the team who works on
Magic is putting in right now and I
think the the the real Crux of like what
it takes to be really good at this stuff
is like the the data prep it is like we
we now have like dedicated ETL pipelines
and storage and processing steps that
we're taking and a lot of the iteration
is on that on how we're using
the data to then prompt the model like
the API calls the easy part right it's
like it's everything up into like what
do you fit in that context window and
how do you process what you're bringing
back for us the the opportunity with
magic is particularly exciting because
we already do have this pretty pretty
big base of people writing queries every
day and connecting us to their their
warehouses and their data catalogs and
enriching us with their DBT models and
so like we have all of this context and
data and like the hard part is like how
do you what if that is useful
to be able to get the right response
from the model
how do you synthesize all of that into a
prompt that's going to help do that and
so the the processing steps and what you
do to to bring that together is actually
become uh probably the single biggest
point of effort for us right now besides
just the the ux I think to go along with
that uh you know between the four of us
up here as panelists Jasper definitely
has the least technical Target user
right where
um uh they're marketers and that's not
saying they're not talk Google I think
there's actually a lot of uh technical
expertise in marketing that I find
really fascinating but but they're not
data scientists or data Engineers as
much by trade as many of your customers
would be right and so
um to go along with that though it's
it's getting the data that that a lot of
them already do have like for for
Jasper's customers a lot of times it's
not data as we think of it uh it might
be like previous content that they've
created it might be like their marketing
site that they want to uh have Jasper or
or their large language models
understand better and that's sort of the
data set that they want to use and so
very similar to what you're saying about
you know a lot of focus being spent on
like how to see like what's important
data to use what's not how does it get
consumed and used in ways to create
better prompts and then therefore or
better output I think it also kind of
comes back to that concept of like a lot
of this is still experience at the end
of the day it's the user experience and
so for Jasper's customers we're going to
be less technical how do we make that
really really simple to where they're
not having to do you know feature
engineering or they're not having to go
and like transform and do all these
things for their own data sets again if
it's like their marketing site we're
trying to make it as easy as possible to
just get that ingested in and we'll do
all the the magic on the back end of it
to make it so it can be used for the
large language models and other area
Technologies to produce better outputs
for them and so I think it's I and I
think what's really interesting about
large language models maybe specifically
that is different than before with all
this I think some of this around
experience has always been true but I
think again we're working with large
language models
um to even do some of the ETL and the
the data curation and things like that
and it's I don't I could be wrong I'm
not sure that was like one of the first
use cases that many of these large
language model providers and creators
had in mind when they created them but
again it's one of those emerging
capabilities that we've found that's
really interesting to use
so when we think about a lot of the
input that's coming into the large
language model there's also as far as
data right there's also a tremendous
value in the output and so let's talk
about that for a moment inference right
there's a lot of opportunity in what's
generated from an inference standpoint
what the possibilities are in rlhf in
terms of reinforcement learning through
human feedback loops it's also a very
expensive proposition today particularly
on some of these large-scaled out large
language models in terms of the cost of
this inference so how do you guys think
about this today as far as where
inferences how rlhf and other methods of
improving models over time from the
output of this data that's generated is
going to change the way we work Sean you
might want to start okay yeah there's
probably two questions here first
inference uh what are the issues there I
mean you're right I think it's not
obvious if you haven't worked with large
language models how big they are and how
compute intensive they are it's one
thing that say that's cool that's a 12
billion parameter model it's another
thing to get it to respond in well under
a second and you can do it but it's a
whole other world of engineering and
tools and concerns and trade-offs so
certainly
um the places that I'm seeing people
start are not real time if possible
there's a lot you can cover a lot of
grounds in batch and streaming and then
this stuff gets easier if you're if
you're not as concerned with latency but
uh but yeah inference is suddenly become
I think it was previously not a big deal
at least in our world sure you made a XG
boost model you want to serve that in
real time it takes a millisecond to
score who cares now that's not true at
all
um our lhf you know I don't think I have
strong uh opinions on that yet so I'm
going to I'm going to pass on that one
to others
me oh uh you're in the middle of big
yeah potato Journey yeah no I think
um
no I think to that point like
um maybe more on like the like whether
it's rlhf or something else
um I think I think something again
another emerging capability that's been
talked about more recently is in like
the last like week or two even
um is this idea of like critiquing the
outputs using another large language
model
um and then even like making suggestions
on like how to improve set output and
things and so I think like um there's
this combination of like humans in the
loop but then also other large language
models in the loop doing some of that
too but I think the idea is
um you know I think with like chat gbt
obviously opening I used
um human feedback to do more of the
fine-tuning and affecting the model
itself again for a lot of us that are
wanting to create large language models
or use large language models we might
not have the capability to do that but
we could still use the output do
something similar to that and instead of
using it to fine-tune it's almost you'll
uh change the prompts change the way
that we're getting data putting into the
model for the input and again using
large language models even to critique
themselves in a way to help us
understand and improve how we go about
doing that so I think there's a lot that
we're still figuring out with that I
think there's that that's a good example
of maybe a more like traditional method
of improving a model that can work but
then there's like other capabilities and
things that we're really trying to still
understand that can help us make models
better from using the output that we've
gotten from them
one quick point to make it occurred to
me on the subjective output we were just
talking about Dolly and alpaca the I
don't know if people didn't see it the
real trick there was to take one model
and fine-tune it on the output of open
AI so the whole trick there was take the
output of a model and use that to make
another model it's an interesting set of
issues there but totally possible the
output can be the input too
well one of the issues being open ai's
terms of service right
um George you talked about cost of
inference
um I think
when we were again we were looking at
this like a year ago we were like well
look at the rates for these API calls
and if like our users actually adopt
this it's going to like bankrupt us
we're gonna have to like we're gonna
have to like charge more and we were
like starting to get down this path of
like well how do we get a price for this
and all this and then we started really
experimenting with Ernest um
a few months ago like we're going to
push some proposed in production and you
know again we started penciling the math
on like the cost of inference was like
oh you know how are we going to charge
for this and all of a sudden we have
this pricing conversation and I'm like
going to open the eye and I'm like hey
could we like to negotiate because if
our users this really takes off you know
we're gonna have to and they're like no
don't worry about that and I was like
what what do you mean like I just uh uh
I was like what look okay here's Early
Access to this thing and it's a new
model and it's one time I was like oh
okay I see why you weren't like trying
to negotiate down I was like if you
would have negotiated like one-third the
cost I would have been happy and you're
like here are the new bass lines one
tenth so my lesson from that uh and I
think in general when we're building
with these models and we're thinking
about cost is it's okay to live in the
future a little bit because I think the
rate right point of cost collapse we're
gonna see is just gonna come so fast I
think you're going to see multiple
factors pushing this you're gonna have
competition in the market so open AI is
just gonna you know they're gonna have
more competition and there's gonna be
downward price pressure
you're gonna have just we're all gonna
get more efficient and better at
training and inference costs like we're
so early in the process of understanding
like how to optimize this from a compute
perspective and so I think as Builders
and as people like going looking to
leverage this like I'm encouraging our
team to like not worry too much about
the costs in the short term because like
yeah like you know the the slopes so far
has been like this and if we extrapolate
it just a little bit I think you can
assume that there's a lot more
efficiency ahead
I think to add to that you know talking
with leaders at open Ai and anthropic
and cohere and others the way they talk
about their own models is still very
like they're big and inefficient and
there's a lot to get out of them to make
them more efficient so yeah I think
you're absolutely right that it's we're
very much in this phase of like we've
discovered this really powerful
technology uh but right now it's just
I'm a big formula one fan we're in
Austin Texas right so I guess it's a
good analogy too um there's a race here
in case you didn't know um to do
whatever year
um but in Formula One For example like
engine technology kind of boomed when it
was like oh my gosh like if we add more
cylinders and make them bigger we get
more power and so you have these huge
fire breathing engines that produced you
know a thousand plus horsepower that
were ginormous and sucked in gasoline at
a crazy rate and everything they're very
inefficient nowadays a Formula One
engine I think is like 1.6 liters and
still produces over a thousand
horsepower so I mean the efficiency is
phenomenal and I think we're kind of at
that Peak with AI where at least with
Gen AI where we're kind of in this like
really big engine big cylinder you know
everyone talks about like how many
hundreds of billions of parameters these
models are uh it's very soon if not like
last week apparently uh we're going to
start talking about how small they can
be and how that can be really powerful
and more efficient
um that they can be better for certain
use cases and more efficient from an
inference and latency cost one more one
more thing by the way you're talking
about reinforcement learning and then
you know logging or like looking at
responses and the outputs we're not
doing any hardcore you know our
relationship right now but one one thing
that's funny when you start going down
this path is like there's a lot of new
and wondrous things when you're working
with generative AI but there's also some
stuff where you're like
this is just everything as old as new
again it's like one of the most
important things is like logging like
you're logging like what the prompt was
and the response and like what version
and then we do experiments now so we
have experimentation and like I I think
there's a lot of things that have been
become like emergent best practices and
there's certainly companies focused on
experimentation like EPO and statsig
that are like I think will be more
relevant than ever actually because
especially with like a stick these like
kind of stochastic models with models
that are changing very quickly where you
are going to be wanting to iterate on
the prompts while the model is also
iterating its versions and you're having
humans giving you feedback on how that
is like we're we're spending a lot of
our energy as mentioning like on the
data prep like a big part of that is
like setting up our own experimentation
framework and our own logging and our
own data storage and that entire
pipeline because we just think there's
ways in which we know that's going to be
useful today and there's also like ways
in which we're like hey we just know
like having this data and being able to
iterate on it and run really good
data-driven experiments is gonna be like
the thing and I would encourage anyone
else like starting to work work with
generated AI to like put in that effort
up front because it I think it will pay
a lot of dividends down the road yeah I
I definitely that that was definitely
our experience also specifically with
copilot like the solution space is so
large and it's so easy to just drown
yourself and like
different combinatoric possibilities of
like you know well what if we try this
style of prompting and what if we try
this kind of like input and wonder if we
try that and all of a sudden you're
sitting there looking at a dashboard
with like 49 000 different things and
like you know I remember this from the
early days of of copilot we're like okay
we have three like different prompt
strategies times however many languages
because it worked well for python but
maybe less well for I don't know Haskell
because there's less Haskell out there
in the world and then but what if we
also control for geo and latency like
you know what happens if we add another
tenth of a second to the amount of time
until we show The Prompt like and all of
a sudden bam I've got 40 charts and what
does it mean and that's really hard to
interpret but um coming back like a step
to the compute side of thing I'm less
worried about inference I'm more worried
about like
where am I going to get a GPU
like I would really like Mr Huang to
like back the GPU truck up and just
throw h100s at me and the new models
they take only the big gpus because they
need that amount of memory on board like
I you know very often I I couldn't pay
to even have the GPU to run the
inference on that's the real problem
that I face right now it's definitely a
short term like I'm sure the supply
chain type stuff will ease up but like
yeah the GPU uh under Supply is is a
massive challenge for the next several
years I don't think that's gonna go away
anytime soon there's there's certainly
some work that's being done on new chips
that are just AI specific that are
happening that go even Beyond gpus
there's work that's happening in terms
of custom silicon that you can
specialize with fpgas but in the newer
term we are a GPU bound World um in that
regard
um and as we think about that right so
there's this sort of you know limitation
on gpus there is another limitation that
we're about to hit when it comes to
public data right because if we look at
gpt4 and this sort of gpt4 style of you
know models that are being built by you
know anthropico here AI 21 Etc
it's likely going to lead into somewhere
around a trillion parameters which is
incredible when you think about it right
um but every one of these generational
efforts that have happened in the
foundation models up to this point you
know we're going to see another order
and magnitude emerge but when we hit
that next order of magnitude let's just
say you know the 10 to 25 trillion
parameters uh there's a tiny little
problem here right which is even if the
loss function on these models continues
to perform as well as they have which is
amazing the Transformers can do this
we're going to run out of human Corpus
like we don't have any more publicly
available data to be able to train these
models
um as someone who's kind of been at this
for a little bit uh in both public and
private use of data how do you how do
you guys think about that right now
um at GitHub
um
I think I'm going to come back to what I
said earlier that the the model that we
have you know the burden the hand
um we haven't even come close to like
tapping the potential of that I think
maybe it's it's it's
um it's the wrong question we should be
thinking more in terms of how are we
going to uh do things like retrieval and
prompt craft better and get more out of
the models that we have today there's
more work to just be done and just just
optimization at this point that we
shouldn't worry about you know running
out of Corpus anytime soon yeah like you
know it's like what do I need more
Corpus for to train better but what's
the purpose of training uh it's to make
the model better but the model is pretty
good so do I is that really the most
important place to spend my time energy
and and money and gpus then I I don't
know I don't I don't I don't necessarily
think so and also fine-tuning has this
problem of like you fine tune or you do
more training and then the model knows
about whatever exists did up until that
point
and it doesn't know about anything that
happens later right so uh techniques
that Mash models together or retrievals
which I keep coming back to
um allows me to use like the same model
we trained last month or however much we
spent on it
um but get results that are fresh and
are able to point to their sources or
cite their sources better
with the model that we have today and
they remain fresh forever I don't need
to constantly be retraining to teach the
model about new developments in the
world if I do a better job of prompt
crafting but that's so much trial and
error so
there was a there was a paper uh what a
couple of months ago I want to call it
the chinchilla paper it wasn't written
by a chinchilla but the the question was
like do we need how do we make progress
bigger models longer training or more
data and basically the answer was more
data that's what we're bottlenecked on
so to your point I think that is data is
the issue but but to edon's point I
don't know if we're nearly to the point
close to the point where we've exploited
all known human data public data but uh
do we even need to be to solve
particular problems I guess that's where
my angle is coming you're not trying to
your business problem is probably not I
need an AGI your business problem is
probably much more specific and you do
have the data for it data is still the
bottleneck but it's private it's a Barry
and Greg's point the private data
becomes more and more important much
more sooner yeah I I think that's the
thing I it's hard the rate of change is
so fast but also like it feels like a
ways off but I I kind of don't doubt it
all and I think it almost feels obvious
that five ten years you know whatever
long enough Horizon you want to put on
which probably even really long in this
space the the future is where where you
have probably these foundational base
models
but a lot a lot a lot potentially like
constant fine-tuning retraining on
private data and whether that's your
company and you're able to leverage a
base model and then have it continually
retraining on the Corpus of private data
that you were producing as exhaust from
your operations every day or in private
and you know we're talking a lot about
like B2B or whatever but like in your
personal life like apple certainly I
think has been on the Forefront of like
on device training and you already see
this with a lot of stuff with like Siri
and the way that they do stuff on the if
you're an iPhone user there already is a
good amount of like training that's
happening on your phone with your photos
and stuff like that and so I'm very
excited to see like I think the Corpus
of data George the Corpus of private
data out there whether it's photos or
texts or emails or love letters or
whatever you have
having that um be able to be part of the
training in a secure way I think is
actually like the probably the most
exciting Frontier that we're going to
get to and I'm very looking forward to
that it's a little dystopian too like I
rewatched her recently and I'm like oh
like that is it was weird how pressured
her this is like it's aged well but also
not well because like it's but uh yeah
it will be interesting so last comment
and question
um for everyone in this audience I don't
know if it's sort of landed upon you
um but hopefully it has in the last six
to months to a year we're embarking on
an incredible journey that in my view
will certainly transform all of software
and most likely all of humanity
and so when we think about that Journey
that we're all on for this next decade
and Beyond
um what are some of the sort of parting
words that each of you have as uh we're
undertaking this incredible journey
together
uh
okay I think one message to this
audience who I think is largely a data
audience is good news I think data is
probably the most important element here
so you're very well positioned to be a
big part of the the AI Revolution
perfect show
yeah I would say that uh we're at a
point now where it's more accessible
than other than ever uh generative AI
that is and that it certainly can play a
part in a lot of what we do both what
you do specifically and then what you're
trying to accomplish for your customer
your company your your personal
Endeavors whatever that is I think it's
worth investing some time into
understanding like how gen AI can play a
part in that and it may not be obvious
where we are in the hype cycle right now
is like
oh my God chat that's mind-blowing I
didn't know a computer could do that but
um I come back to what Barry said
earlier it's all about value and
happiness satisfaction like that's
durable that's gonna stick around and
making sure that whatever you're doing
is not just being impressed by what the
computer responded but actually doing
something that's going to make
developers or whoever your customer is
happier
that that's Peak concern and that's what
I think about every day
I'm very worried about
I think we have to I'm I'm trying to
contribute in some small way and also
like to potentially delusionally
optimistic that generative AI is going
to be a thing that will help amplify and
uh augment and improve The Human
Experience I think if it turns out to be
something that um Sidelines humans uh or
potentially further furthers the sort of
quasi-dystopian type thing that we might
have going on with some of our
technology today there will be a lot of
societal up people so I want to invite
everyone who's here like who's building
software and thinking about this to like
help contribute to like human-centric
Solutions because I think if we don't
find a way for that to be how this
manifests bear is absolutely right here
I mean when you think about this like
there are sort of forks in the road here
right and things go really badly things
go really well or somewhere in between I
would kind of close to this and say like
in 1960 jcr lichlider wrote a paper on
human machine symbiosis and what he said
ultimately was that machines are here to
help humans do greater things to be more
creative to be more productive to 10x to
next suit what we're capable of doing
um in in our work lives and our personal
lives and I think where generative AI
could lead us is exactly that this
opportunity to have Mech suits available
like the ones that you've built today so
really important give this sort of
audience and this panel here a great
Round of Applause they're doing
incredible work in this area please
spend time talk to them thank you again
everyone
[Music]